[Music]
can
I are you are you preparing a speech for
the Oscar how do you feel I kind of made
a list of of uh of people I you know I
have to than and I was up there I'm sure
I've left out so many people people you
know uh because that's one of the
wonderful things about making movies
it's a collaborative art form you know
there's so many people that are
responsible for for this
award makeup
person other actors that we work with
couldn't mention Ryan B there so many
wonderful people that uh are all a part
of this how do you feel about your Oscar
chances on Sunday it's pretty much a
slam J based on your queen I'm not
counting any chickens you know but uh
it's wonderful to be in that in that
great company of uh the other nominees
and it's always wonderful to get the nod
from your from your guys you your peers
you do what you
do what did you your wife you're going
off stage and could you elaborate on
your
PL I say uh oh my God like that I can't
remember the exact line I said to her
and after this I'm not sure really
what's what's up
but as you as you were going out the
stage you said something like we're
going to go out you
tell what did I said what do you think I
said this is what I was walking up yeah
walking out I mean on the speech oh what
I said oh what did I say to my wife oh
oh I said this is really going to tie
the room
together it's a little nod to the
dude you you go from this most
independent movie to your next one is
the long awaited Tron legacy how
exciting was the double role you got to
play in that oh that was very exciting
you know uh somebody asked
me uh just a moment ago about the
difference between you know these big
budget films and independent films and a
lot of them a lot of it is very similar
you know uh some of these big budget
films um Tron and uh an Iron Man um you
think you were doing a a student film
sometimes you
people are very you know the scripts
aren't written completely a lot of
improvisation a big budget but there's a
lot of similarities to it you know one
of the things that perhaps is different
is that really what drives the
independent film is that passion of a of
the filmmaker you know you get something
you know bubbles up from uh for like a
100,000 bucks that filmed once was a
couple years ago you know such a
wonderful wonderful film you know things
like that you know to toh stick to it
and make a film like that it really
takes
passion and that's
really uh after Sunday are you looking
forward to not wearing cowboy boots and
slightly larger than regulation belt
buckles I really like these these boots
these were made for me for uh for Wild
Bill I like these are Comfort thank you
thank you very much thanks everyone
congratulations good luck
Monday